please welcome Bryan Adams
welcome thank you welcome this is Helena
this is Grayson this is Johnson hi guys
all right um it's great to have you on
the show
thank you um Connie is it possible to
describe how it was back back in two
days when you when you went from from
being just a normal person to super high
me we are still a normal person but you
know you became a superstar like
overnight and do you have to have a
memory of how that was vague but yeah
there's I have a recollection that
because when I started out in the 70s I
didn't have anything I used to borrow
money off my my co-writer which I still
work with today to get back and forth on
the bus to my house and so when we
started we didn't have much and so when
we finally started selling millions of
albums there's no there's no instruction
manual for success and so I'm I think
I'm grateful that I had some good
friends around me and a good band which
I'm still with as well um did people
that people recognize you suddenly I'm
gonna it was like was that a shock feet
yeah I mean there's one particular story
I have which which is when I was playing
in New York at Madison Square Gardens
and I was so used to taking the taxis
because I'd been working in New York for
a number of years so I sort of knew
where I was going but it's one of those
nice to know if anyone's ever been in
New York that there's this wasn't a taxi
um of course you don't have that now you
can just dial it up on your phone but
did just no taxis anywhere and I had to
be at a gig Madison Square Garden yeah
oh wait I was down in Soho so that I was
get on the train so I got on the train
but I didn't realize that all the people
on the train were going to my gig and so
I and I remember sitting thinking I was
sort of standing by the doors like you
what have I done I saw what you did the
other lives like know that there was one
guy going because the T sorry but hey it
continues cuz I when I got off the train
and I got up to 32nd Street I think um I
didn't know which way to go like is it
that way or is that way I'm so looking
around and it's kind of nice now you you
broke Adams I said yeah because
you're on the train I said dude help me
out which way is Madison Square Garden
just follow the other people so that's
when I kind of I suppose that was when
the penny really dropped and I knew that
things weren't gonna be quite the same
at least for that but your period of my
life you you have you have been working
with a lot of the same people and I'm
trying to get rid of him but I can't
hope is there not I mean you have the
same manager yes you used to have in the
beginning now he must he doesn't know a
lot he knows a lot I know a lot about
him too yeah well yeah it's a sort of a
terror thing that listen when you've had
a long relationship with somebody it's
there's something beautiful about
loyalty and yeah I mean those guys are
just great guys to be with and I can't
imagine doing with anybody else
really it's it's quite beautiful your
your father was a military man did you
have a did you have a strict upbringing
or a quite strict yeah so what what did
he think of you becoming this rock rebel
of I mean were you an easy song
territory to race um well I don't think
there was yeah I don't think anybody
that comes from that sort of academic he
was a Sandhurst officer looking at his
son as a hair got longer and longer and
his hair got shorter and shorter um was
necessarily happy about the idea of dad
I'm gonna be a musician you know it's
like what now it was never in fact we
never even had that conversation
everything that was gearing towards
music was always trying to shuffled away
my mother on the other hand was of a
free spirit and she was quite happy for
me to be creative so and your dad lived
to see what he became my father lives
with me now
okay so he needs a yogi yeah
it's two ways of seeing that is you live
with your father or your father lives
with you and I I noted that you you said
your father lives with you
yeah he lives with me because um it's my
house and he's not allowed to bring in
his ham sandwiches in the house you know
but there were some years that you
didn't have contact you didn't talk yeah
that was my parents split up um but I
resolved that by going to find him and
and making amends and you know staring
him in the face
I just found out that you you life it
was too short all right well no I just
felt that you know he was my dad you
know it's like okay they had a problem
doesn't mean I have a problem so you
know we're sure that we can we can talk
whatever whatever the problem is if
there was a problem let's sort it out
yeah it was quite many years yeah it was
a few years and I was I was very happy
to have done it I have to say you know
cuz I recommend it to those that are
questioning the idea of finding out
their parents because it's it's a it's a
very fulfilling thing to have done I
mean nothing comes easy of course you
know you if you decide to take that
journey they will there will be
repercussions and OBO there'll be
heartache and there will be
disappointment but in the big picture
that's what you have to look at you know
it will it will help you you're a father
yourself today of two two young girls
right yeah uh and you're not that
straight